welcome to my new video series known as
bio techniques explained in less than
five minutes where I explained
biological concepts in less than five
minutes or so so if you haven't yet
subscribe to my channel please subscribe
and hit that subscribe button so today's
topic is enzyme linked immunosorbent
assay or Eliza so this assay is a
colorimetric
test that uses antibodies and color
development reaction to identify as
certain substances like antigens or it
could be also used for detection of
antibodies now Eliza gives a qualitative
and quantitative information about the
presence of an antigen or an antibody
Eliza is widely used as diagnostic test
for many viral diseases including HIV
AIDS now in Eliza the reactions are set
up in a 96-well plate and that is read
in a common metric machines so where
which is a colorimetric detector
basically which measures the absorbance
of specific wavelength and the result is
displayed in a computer screen and the
result is basically absorbance versus
concentration from that we understand
how much we get the quantitative and
qualitative information about how much
quantity of substance is present now
there are three variants of Eliza we
would discuss one by one by one so the
first variant is indirect Eliza which is
used to detect an antibody against a
known antigen so when we know our
antigen we want to understand whether
there is unknown and what antibody binds
to it we would do our indirect Eliza in
this situation wells of the microtiter
plate are coated with known antigen here
the antigens are marked in yellow then
the antibody to be tested is added into
the wells hopefully that if the antibody
is
specific against that antigen it would
bind to that antigen now our
enzyme-linked secondary antibody is
given and while substrate is provided
the enzyme would give rise to product
and that results in color development so
if the color is developed that is an
indirect proof that the sample that we
provided has that specific antibody
against the antigen which is coating the
surface of these 96 for the plate so
that is how we understand whether our
antibody is present in a particular
biological sample example a patient's
blood or a patient serum etc so this
kind of technique is used to detect HIV
so let's say this human is infected by a
HIV virus and have has AIDS so it's a
hiv-positive human being so as for time
for diagnostic tests his blood is
collected and centrifuge to form the
serum so from the from the serum
fraction we could get the antibodies
generated against the HIV virus proteins
or HIV viral antigens so we know if HIV
virus effect that person and the person
is HIV positive so the antibodies would
be produced in his body if we can detect
those antibodies then we would have a
idea that whether the person is infected
or not so definitely in order to
understand that we would do a indirect
laser so we would see if the antigen is
present that means the person is HIV
positive if the antigen
if the antibody is absent the present is
HIV negative now in a lab what would
happen is they would give the patient
serum serum into the well so which is
previously coated by antigens present on
the viral surface so if the serum
contains the antibody against the viral
antigen then it would definitely buy it
in the antigens coated on the surface of
the web and thereby when we put the
secondary antibody enzyme-linked it
would develop a color yeah
upon giving a substrate but on the other
hand side if the patient serum doesn't
have that antibody produced that doesn't
have the antibody produce should that
should be produced in a viral response
then there would be no color reactions
because the secondary antibodies doesn't
bind to a primary antibody hand unable
to give a color reaction so that would
be HIV negative there are other variants
known as sanducci lyza which is used to
detect antigen of interest for example
we wanted to detect an antigen with our
hand each end is present in a patient's
blood sample or not so what we can do we
know that antigen binds to specific
monoclonal antibody so we can coat the
well of the microtiter plate with
monoclonal antibody after that we can
give the patient's serum or patient
blood or anything like bodily fluid like
that and then we can give another
monoclonal antibody coupled with enzyme
and then we put the substrate now if
their second if the monoclonal antibody
coupled with enzyme is binding to that
particular antigen then in a color would
develop that would tell indeed that
antigen is present in the patient sample
or patients blood so that is how we
understand whether antigen is present in
the sample or not whether indirect
eliezer tells us about whether antibody
is present or not now once we know and
the gene is present another question is
that how to reject how much antigen is
present and competitively lanza give us
an understanding about that so you're
going to be competitively Liza you know
you you are you are asking a question
that how much antibody is produced in a
patient sample or huh so definitely how
much antigen is produced in a patient
sample so what you would do you
previously incubate some antibodies
which you know it is produced against
these yellow antigens and then what you
would do would coat a surface of the
well
DCL Oh antigens now if the antigens are
present in ample then all the antibodies
we provide against it would bind and
there would be very less amount of free
antibodies available to bind to these
antigen coated surface so once we give
it so what would happen is most of the
antibody would be enough floating
condition because it cannot bind to the
antibody Co and the antigen quote of the
quills so ultimately faint color would
be developed so there are two
possibilities one is there is a
dark-colored reaction happening that
means there is very I mean if the dark
color is developing the antigen
concentration is very low because as the
antigen is low when we incubate with
antibody few antibodies bind to the
antigen but most of the antibodies are
now free which can in turn burn bind to
the antigens coated onto the surface of
the well and when we provide secondary
antibody it can give rise to a color
reaction but if there is too much of
antigen present then once we provide our
antibody against that antigen almost all
the antibodies are occupying that
antigen and now when we provide the
whole solution into the Eliza will if
there is no more free antibody which can
bind to the surface coated antigens
that's why once we provide the secondary
antibody after you faint color or no
color is developed so that is how we
understand that how much antigen is
present so if it's more antigen then so
if a lot of antigen is present then a
very faint color would be developed in a
competitive in East Eliza but if there
is very less amount of antigen then the
dark color would be developing in the
competitive Eliza so that is all about
Eliza so I hope you enjoyed this video
if you liked my video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you